i i picked something that i had been
wanting to learn more about since 1997
and just never
figured out how to do it yeah no
justification
i mean i've never needed justification
for anything i think you know that about
me
i've learned that about you yes
you made it sound like i drove through
your front door
this is a topic near and dear to my
heart as a former
ninja turtle head
um so i've wanted to talk about this for
a long time and i would love to talk to
you two about it so nina uh
out of the ninja turtles rip-offs we
kind of briefly discussed before this
chat what was the one that you kind of
wanted to expound on a bit what was the
one that you found most fascinating
well the one that uh really grabbed my
attention is a
it started running in uh 1990 and then
it ran
until uh 1991 so nice long run
uh of 52 episodes
and it is called samurai pizza cats
um and while i was googling the many
teenage mutant ninja turtle spin-offs um
i rip offs
no spin-offs just rip-offs
i consider this canon brian um
because it involves pizza
no uh yeah
yeah yeah exactly into the pizza verse i
was entranced by samurai pizza cats
mostly because the song for it
is
catchy as hell it like the theme song he
took cats samurai pizza cats and it also
does that thing that they always did on
cartoons in the mid 80s and early 90s
where the theme song is like two minutes
long and it just tells you all of the
characters and what they do and what
their deal is um which is like one of my
favorite things because nobody does that
anymore but every old cartoon is like
every kid just sat there for two minutes
and they know who the characters are
presumably if they watch the show but
they get it explained to them every time
so
i assume you two drill it into their
yeah
and then they know so are you two
i have to assume that you two are
familiar with samurai pizza cats
i am somewhat familiar passing
familiarity with samurai pizza yeah so
sing us a song tell us about the
characters well samurai pizza cats uh
was uh set in a fiction in the fictional
town of little tokyo um and
it was filled with what is described as
uh
cybernetic anthropomorphic animals so
just robots and it has an emperor but
he's not really in charge there's a very
intricate like plot for the leadership
of the city going on in this children's
cartoon and so there's a city council uh
and it's headed by
seymour the big cheese like his nickname
is the big and his name is seymour
cheese so that's very good i want to be
clear about the order of those things
and he's a rat surprising no one he has
like
cohorts who do his bidding named
geriatric and bad bird and they lead an
army of crows which i guess is called a
murder of crows but they probably didn't
call them that in a children's cartoon
um however
there is a secret uprising led by
big al dente
my favorite character name in the show
and he leads uh three little robot
cats who are the titular samurai pizza
cats and um
their names are speedy ceviche
guido anchovy and the token girl
polyester but my favorite part of
samurai pizza cats is those three you
know it's like they lead double lives
they you know try to
defeat the corruption of the city
council by night but by day they run a
pizza parlor and they don't change
outfits or their appearance at all to
work at the pizza parlor so they just
look the same all the time but no one
can figure out that they're also the
vigilantes like saving the city from
corruption
and also the top of the pizza parlor is
a giant gun
right that they used to fight it's like
a revolver right
yeah it's a huge revolver um so
there were some controversies with this
show there was some appropriation
controversies there were um there were
controversies where it like would name
stuff like chuck e cheese but i'm not
sure it had the rights to name stuff
like chuck e cheese so they would have
to pull the episodes from air to not get
sued um and i found a really great fact
on a little website called wikipedia and
it says citation needed but i need this
to be true so just let it be true um it
says
that uh one of the writers uh michael
arrington uh
sang the theme song for the series
saying samurai pizza cats and apparently
he uh imbibed a little before the
recording and so he just stumbles over a
couple lines and they left those stumbly
lines in the original recording so if
you listen carefully you can hear a kind
of drunk guy singing the theme song for
a children's cartoon i'm fine with that
anyway i'm going with samurai pizza cats
i want to watch every episode of this
it's actually on peacock so i might but
um
it's insane everything about it is
is offensively weird and i love it it's
perfect yeah
wow that sounds great
samurai pizza cats
if you go watch the intro i dare you to
not get the song stuck in your head it's
been stuck in my head for days
it's second i walk around my house just
going like this
like all the time
just how i live
i blame this show how did this nut take
off
this is amazing
probably because of all the controversy
and the slightly drunk people making it
yeah probably tom what about drunk
people making things and controversy is
like 90 of what's on tlc like at any
given point right
why is this not a bigger franchise and
also frankly like some of the great art
in
the history of the world but
absolutely
but still for some reason samurai pizza
cast just didn't didn't hit tom
what was what was your pick for the tmnt
ripoff that you wanted to talk about
today
okay i was i was actually i was really
excited that we got to talk about this
because uh i i picked something that i
had been wanting to learn more about
since 1997
and just never
figured out how to do it yeah no
justification
i mean i've never needed justification
for anything i think you know that about
me
i've learned that about you yes
[Laughter]
you made it sound like i drove through
your front door
not yet
not yet
just wait until i get my giant roof gun
then you'll be sorry
exactly
my pizza parlor
sorry tom go on
so in the later in in the in the second
half of the 1990s this is like this is
probably post
the point where
turtle fever which you brought up
earlier which i think is just called
salmonella right
i was gonna say was that one of the
great pandemics of the 90s turtle
yeah it was
my i remember my mom wouldn't let me get
a turtle because she was afraid that i
would get turtle fever
so like so we're well past the point
where we're still color coding
anthropomorphic animals and giving them
like specific weapons at this point i
feel like
children's entertainment has kind of
moved on at this point we're we're just
about to start doing pokemon
uh
anyway
so there was this group of of four
brothers uh these independently wealthy
dudes who uh who decided that they
wanted to get into movies they made a
production studio that was hopefully
called four brothers productions and
they made a movie called warriors of
virtue
with no experience having made movies at
this point uh it was this it was this
wildly expensive
bizarre film directed by the guy that
would go on to make uh classics like
freddy versus jason and the bride of
chucky
uh so like that's
that's where the bar is right now just
just to be clear uh
the story is about this kid who uh and i
i don't know growing up around this time
like if you ever rented a vhs from a
blockbuster or a hastings for a kids
movie
there was almost always an ad for this
movie and like it looked intriguing when
i was a kid yes and then i i i looked
into like i remember seeing ads for it
yeah
i know for sure i remember the ads i
remember toys but i never yeah
i feel like there were were there like
happy meal toys or something
almost definitely yeah no like i feel
like they they pulled out all the stops
to make this movie it was the prevailing
feeling i have about this movie when i
recall it is that everything i seem to
recall everything looks dirty
like it's dank and every like there's
just like these like
these anthropomorphic kangaroos doing
doing martial arts and i just i in my
mind i just smell like wet dog
everything looks dirty in that
everything looks like it's a community
theater production like yeah uh for the
most part perfect aside from the the the
animal like the uh
the the prosthetics that the character
makeup is what i'm imagining
so most of the sets look like you're
backstage on the nightmare coming like
it's it's it's it's like a painted
window yeah
very much yeah yeah uh also the story
real hard to parse uh there is a kid
with leg braces who uh
makes friends with a
guy who works at a chinese restaurant
and the guy who works at the chinese
restaurant tells him about
vaguely uh
uh
asian uh mythology and the kid that
sticks with him apparently because when
the kid falls into
a water treatment plant and almost
drowns he gets transported
to a world uh inhabited by a bunch of
colorful characters there's all these
these weird animals the the
there's like there's a giant yak that's
standing in the middle of the village
like really the character design is
gorgeous uh there's also uh the cat from
uh
twin peaks uh the man from another place
the the
little uh michael j anderson was the
actor's name uh oh wow but the way that
they've shot him like it's it's a little
uncanny he looks exactly like andy
circus which like brings up a lot of
questions about like maybe maybe did
they get andy circus is this what andy
circus actually looks like and he's an
actual cgi character in real life like
what we don't know uh to this day we do
not know
the the bad guy
is an actor named angus mcfadden he's he
was he was the
he's from uh braveheart he's the bad guy
in that so there's angus
and he is terrific to me in this because
he looks
uncanny it's uncanny how much he looks
like uh
ricky gervais from back
[Laughter]
that was pretty good
yeah
that's good
okay so if you if you saw the trailers
for this this movie as a kid you thought
like this is going to be worries of
virtue is going to be a movie about
kangaroos doing kung fu
and if you thought that and then you
rented the movie it turns out that you
were going to learn a virtue of your own
which is
inhuman patience the kangaroos don't
show up
until 33 minutes into the movie how long
is the movie total 90.
i want to say just shy of that but maybe
like yeah they really
like they poured money into this it was
it was
this is the mid 90s it was a 35 million
dollar movie uh
and uh
it made
6.5 million of that back uh
yikes and they made a sequel anyway
they did of course i think the same four
guys decided that they they weren't done
with the story so they they they funded
they made a sequel
to the warriors of virtue uh but this
time and i'm sure that this had nothing
to do with the fact that they were doing
it on a tv budget the kangaroos in
between movies had stopped looking like
kangaroos and started looking like
television actors
got it
amazing i want to say it was a sci-fi
original it was terrific yup yup don't
it's agonizing it is difficult to watch
perfect or do live your life you know
i'm not your dad
i'm running out of content here so i
gotta take what i can get sometimes
um so
i've always been fascinated by these
rip-offs and things i was like i know
brian's got a good answer yeah i mean i
don't know how good it is i'm just going
to run through a few things like i
watched turtles back in the day i was a
big fan the original run original flavor
i was totally into that stuff and as
these other shows were coming out at the
time i didn't think that they were
rip-offs it didn't quite click with me
that they were
um i'll just read off a few that i
remember from back in the day and one i
noticed recently while searching for
them uh one i used to watch was biker
mice from mars which like teenage mutant
ninja turtles is exactly what it sounds
like there are these biker mice
and they're from mars biker mice that's
going to be my next question where do
they now they're on earth and they ride
their motorcycles around and cool bad
guys
another one i remember from back then
was street sharks which was actually
really popular
were they sharks on the street
they were literally
guys turned into sharks and they fought
crime on the streets
i was really worried it was just regular
dudes who call themselves sharks
no that's west side story you're
confused
no i was just worried i was you were
just gonna say i'm just talking about
west side story a famous ripoff of
teenager ninja turtles
but there's there's a famous video of
vin diesel at toy fair
um have you seen this video
yeah
nina
he had hair
yeah what i'm gonna pull this up hang on
am i gonna be frightened by his hair
you're going to be jarring
get ready to fall in love with vin
diesel all over again america
i'm going to share that with you
oh my god he does have hair yeah and
he's wearing a leather vest
yeah this was freaking like
it wasn't for two oh my god he's just
playing with toys
it was a presentation he was giving at
toy fair which is a trade show for
retailers to come stock toys basically
that's all it is so he was just yeah but
this is so pure
it's really it's honestly really nice
because he's like he's an he's a young
actor and he's trying to make a living
and he's just giving it his all because
he can't like you know at no point will
anyone ever say that vin diesel doesn't
always like at least like give give a
good yeah give a good try whether you
think he's doing a good job or not he's
always in it yeah he's always he's
always giving it 110 yeah yeah uh family
uh so that's street sharks another one i
i saw when just looking things up i saw
a commercial for something i'd never
heard of called snailians
which is little little aliens
snails that are aliens and they have the
names of presidents instead of famous
painters
nina were you were you already familiar
with aliens or were you just putting
that together in your head like out loud
i just wanted to close it
i wanted to guess correctly and i wanted
the victory of guessing correctly so i
shouted it before you could tom
great no you did terrific i just i
wasn't sure if you were like a hardcore
snail stand
from day one by this time next week i
will be
give me give me some time to my
knowledge i think that was just a toy
and not there was no show or anything
associated with it unfortunately okay
let's reboot it then
the thing that made me really want to
explore this is a is a property called
stone protectors and i've talked to you
before about how fascinated i am by this
stone protectors was
in the 90s an attempt on the parts of
some media executives to say hey you
know what's popular troll dolls you know
who doesn't buy troll dolls boys let's
give them muscles and super powers
and so it's literally action figures
buff troll dolls with little jets so
like all the troll dolls have a little
jewel in their tummies
right like so these are have jewels on
their like chests because they're stone
protectors they protect because they're
men
yes because they're for men cool men who
don't have tummy buttons that's right
only on their chest
and so and so i always like the opposite
of true but yeah go on i've always known
about this show i've never watched it um
i finally watched a few episodes and i
am happy to report that it is
moronic it's the dumbest thing i've ever
seen in my life it's so stupid
it wasn't like
yeah like charlie kaufman cut his teeth
writing episodes no no no no it's like
no no no no no no no jones like really
inspired by stone protectors
it's like this there were two ninja
turtles i went back to wat to re-watch
the first episode just to be like do i
just like this because i liked it when i
was a kid and it's i i legitimately
laughed out loud a couple times it's
like it's a pretty good show it's you
know it's for kids but it knows what it
is it has a sense of humor about itself
street sharks it's fine it's it's like
dumb but it's fine like there's nothing
about it that's insulting um biker mice
from mars like there's a james bond
reference in the middle of the
introduction of episode 8 which i just
sampled before we got on this recording
at random i was like oh that's pretty
funny that's pretty clever like it's
you can tell the people making these
things care about it stone protectors is
so soulless and stupid at one point one
of the characters is like asking like
why do we have stones in our chests and
the the lady the princess who's like
their their what their band manager or
whatever she's just like that's just the
way it is like literally like that's
just the way it is that's a line of
dialogue that they wrote for her to say
because they couldn't come up with
anything plausible as to why the show
they made is the way it is
you know brian you're throwing a lot of
information at us very fast you said
band manager i can't remember did you
mention that they were in a rock band
earlier okay so here's how to catch
thank you thank you so these these five
dudes are in a band and they're all
terrible at music like they're in a band
and they're all awful and only one of
them thinks that they're any good and
he's the lead singer cornelius they get
zapped by a beam from another dimension
planet i don't know and they get sucked
into the other planet and they get no
but before that happens they get turned
into these ugly troll people and they
get muscles and all of a sudden they're
just good at this yes yeah
so they started out as human beings yes
and then they become stone protectors
and i'm gonna run through the roster i
don't fully remember all of the names
but it doesn't matter because they're
all awful um the lead singer is
cornelius he is a samurai of some kind
okay he has like a sonic voice power
thing
there's a
drummer
i don't remember his name
is does he wear no he's a rock climber
um why because 90s well how else are you
going to protect stones without climbing
on top of them first the bass player is
dressed like a a a professional wrestler
naturally
which one
doesn't matter
it matters to me there's a keyboard
player named angus with the worst
scottish accent i've ever heard in my
life and he becomes kitted out with
grenades and his keyboards like shoot
lasers and he can like make things and
it doesn't make any sense
give us your best angus real quick like
can we just get away
no no i won't trick him into that this
is embarrassing enough i'm not going to
double down i'm just asking what does
angus sound like when he talks it's the
worst um like if you wish to say
something like do you know why don't you
do what you think it sounds like because
i don't know what angus is making an
educated tom yeah i have no idea i've
never watched stone protectors that's
why we came to you brian brian if angus
had to say something like for example
oh his arse is out the windy what do you
think that would sound like it sounds
just like that you nailed it
then there's
i think the guitar player is a
rollerblader because it's i thought you
were going to say he's a rollerblade
like a sentient rollerblade i was
excited
lead singer
keyboard bass player guitar drums yeah
that's everybody so we've got a samurai
a wrestler a combat keyboard player a
rollerblader a rock climber
it all makes sense it's just like it
i think the makeup of the rolling stones
was like exactly what you just described
this
ninja turtles is a crazy concept right
it's like teenage mutant ninja turtles
you're cramming a bunch of nouns
together but
but it's all like
it's one
it's one unifying idea right this is
like what if troll dolls were strong and
also rollerbladed and rock climbed and
was a wrestler and had grenades and was
a samurai and also i don't know
rollerbladed did i say that one doesn't
matter it's the too many cooks of um of
children's cartoons
did you say grenades
you can yeah he's got grenades all on
him like he's just like he's like kitted
out with actual explosives it's insane
and so like you can just like watching
it you can just see the cocaine on the
boardroom
you know like on the screen for all to
see just like yeah make this show it
doesn't matter if it's good we got to
get the toys on the shelves yeah and the
less money you put into it now means the
more money we're gonna make later when
grandparents are fooled into buying them
because they almost look like ninja
turtles quick yeah get it done
positively don't rewrite it don't worry
about it just go
so yeah my brother and i both really
wanted we wanted to make a kids show
called gun owls
[Laughter]
there was a it was a ninja turtles
ripoff just like this only like instead
of having nunchucks and samurai swords
and stuff they all had different kinds
of guns and the and
the idea would be that every episode
they had to bring in a new main villain
because they had shot the one
and you know what
they had last week it sounds like if
if stone protectors could be made then i
don't see why you can't still hold out
hope
this seemed like like an over-the-top
idea until i found out that one of the
stone protectors is carrying around frag
grenades
that's how they're dealing with their
issues
how do you learn something at the end of
each episode if you have if you're stuck
with grenades you never need to learn it
brought in
that fifth ninja turtle if they brought
in venus de milo in the live-action
series the one that everybody hated and
she had just had like a rocket launcher
and that was that was the end of every
episode i just dropped a picture in our
chat and you can see this is what angus
looks like you can see the grenades are
clearly painted holy [ __ ] oh my god yeah
i'm telling you i wasn't kidding around
is that a horrifying thing to say is he
missing a tooth
yes
is that on purpose what happened
to accident
it doesn't matter
a grenade accident
so i mean i didn't even tell you
they fight like evil trolls they're like
evil trolls who want the stones oh
there's evil versions of the trolls with
grenades yeah well here i'll i'll send
you this picture this is there's so much
to improve this is zock he's the evil
he's the evil bad guy he does look evil
that purple hair yeah
honestly i see a guy who's using a stick
to fight a guy who has grenades grenades
but i mean it doesn't matter none of
this matters
you know how like in rock paper scissors
like paper covers rock i think grenades
cover magic in most
they cover most things right
overall everything unless he has a magic
spell that makes grenades not grenades
anymore i don't see how he's
and there i'm not you know what i'm not
here to argue this useful harry potter
spell
there's the most useful harry potter
spell the spell that makes grenades not
grenade anymore
true episodes late but we got it so all
i can say about stone protectors is that
it's absolute dog so don't watch it
and that's the end of that one
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video and tell your friends and leave a
nice comment don't be mean we read all
the comments please don't be mean to us
thank you